let me pull up this story from abc news
ladies and gentlemen i give you ahmed
arbory day that's right holiday
officially celebrating the second
anniversary of the death of ahmed arbury
february 23rd will permanently be
permanently recognized be permanently
recognizes ahmed arbory day in georgia
they say the ahmed aubry foundation a
mental wellness organization focused on
black men that was founded by aubry's
mother wanda cooper jones announced the
nonprofit will offer six 3 000
scholarships for higher education
opportunities to seniors from arbory's
former high school now i want to start
by saying um that's fantastic if if
they're going to give money for kids to
scholarships i'm not a big fan of
colleges or anything like that but if
they're trying to genuinely help people
i got no issue there but talk about the
psychotic cult world we live in in which
ahmed arbury is getting a holiday for
him look
i uh maybe i'll be one of the few people
willing to uh call out as it should be
called out
but uh during the ahmed aubry trial so
we just had those the the three
individuals in question mcmichaels and
the other guy they're convicted on
federal hate crime charges
you've got uh you've got a story that is
very clearly nuanced and contentious and
it is not as clear-cut as the
establishment and mainstream media tried
to say the fact is the narrative of a
guy jogging down the street was a total
fabrication a lie to manipulate people
that brings us to a point where now
we're having a holiday for this guy look
i'm sad the guy lost his life and all
that stuff but it's not so simple we can
say that mcmichaels were wrong the guy
who filmed all of it happening i don't
know why he's going to prison but sure
fine whatever
the fact is
this is the level of insanity in this
country i gotta say so the guy with the
camera went to jail i think because he
had a car and he was behind him and they
thought it was he was part of like
pinching the guy in like like blocking
the guy in okay if that guy's going to
jail for using his car as a weapon think
about these truckers if they go around
dc and pin the president in while he's
trying to give a speech oh come on come
on yeah come on come on but look what
they did to them
no it's sort of the situation it totally
is isn't it yeah the guy with the
cameras in jail because he had a car
there yeah that's completely five feet
away from it and what was the reason he
went to jail because they said that was
part of it we're having a conversation
about ahmed arbor he's a little off
topic there's nothing to do with trucks
well the camera guy shouldn't have
gotten went to jail i don't think that
guy should have the jail he was there
but they said that he was pinning ahmed
arbory in basically he was he was like
blocking him from running and when he in
no way coordinated with the other man
but it didn't matter because we live in
a psychotic cult reality where lunatics
the the the inmates are running the
asylum
yeah i mean i don't know how he got this
day faster than george floyd
yeah what's up is there a george floyd
day or no i don't know yeah i don't even
know if this is even george floyd yeah
but the fact that uh aubry got it
quicker than him uh i think look at this
the george the georgia general assembly
passed a resolution on february 2nd to
permanently declare february 23rd to be
ahmed arbory day
you know
i don't know
look man
i'm all about justice i i don't like
racists if a group of guys are chasing
down a dude who's jogging because he's
black i want to see justice if they if
they kill him lock those people up you
go to prison for that but that's not
what happened the media lied about
everything and you know what's funny is
conservatives many of them not all of
them but a lot of them are complicit in
pushing this narrative and it's it's
fascinating
i i we've heard it before but i
genuinely think a lot of republicans
they they they try and act like they
oppose the democrats but they're so
they're so worried about not being uh
they're so worried about
what the left thinks of them stepping
out yeah yeah so i mean what we see fox
news we saw even you know tulsi gabbard
i guess she's a progressive but all
these these people are coming out being
like see
what happened here in georgia was right
and i'm like what how are you gonna come
out and be like what happened to kyle
rittenhouse was wrong and the media lied
and now believe the media on this story
when it was just patently false what
happened the story is i'll simplify it
for you a string of robberies in a
neighborhood
gun gets stolen police go door to door
saying this is the guy with an image of
him he's seen on security camera footage
entering someone's house the prosecutor
said that makes him a felony burglary
suspect under georgia law you can
citizens arrest someone without probable
cause
with only probable cause without
actually witnessing it if they're
committing a felony
based on the judge's jury instruction he
said i don't know you figured out and so
the jury decided to go the other way and
say they needed to be witnesses that's
the nuance here as for why these guys
got convicted were the jury instructions
correct but the story about a guy
jogging down the street complete lie
complete lie and now the georgia general
assembly is giving this dude a a a
statewide holiday
didn't they whatever man didn't the guy
wearing work boots yeah something like
that wearing work boots they said he was
jogging i mean come on you don't got you
know what it is it's literally abc says
he was killed while jogging in this same
there is several witnesses that came out
and spoke on record that they suspected
it was it was a monk because they've
already kind of seen some of the
previous behavior uh
leading up to that moment that it was a
what that they believed that it was um
aubry um doing some of the
trespassing according to some of the
neighbors that's like yeah so i made
this mistake and we had a lawyer on uh
we had i think it was andrew branca as
well as another lawyer i can't remember
who do we have on with branca
anyway
was it cash right right right and he was
yes and he was a prosecutor so um
i said trespassing and they said he
wasn't a trespassing suspect when you
when you enter someone so i'll tell you
guys what we're dealing with we had a
guy
drive past two no trespassing signs up a
thousand foot driveway and then enter
our house that is i think it's what is
it fourth degree burglary
that's it
when you when you break a barrier when
you cross a barrier it's burglary at
least in maryland so when they're saying
this guy was trespassing no no no no no
trespassing is if he stepped on the
grass and a sign said no trespassing
then they can be like you knew the sign
there you should have done it by
entering the building it was now felony
burglary so look i don't think the guy
should be dead
don't think we should have a holiday for
him either i mean this is crazy they're
encouraging communities to quote run
with mod by running 2.23 miles annually
on this day this is from the article
literally if the guy is actually running
from a from a burglary and they want to
make a day
encourage people to do like a a run with
the guy who was running from a burglary
he just committed like how how upside
down is this
reality that they've got people confused
like this i mean i don't get it i mean
if you want to have a obvious like a
holiday for like a malcolm x then of
course uh but this is they're putting up
statues of george let me tell you guys
something
this is a story that blows my mind thank
you what i'm you're probably going to
say something that's going to blow my
mind
i love it
i already said thank you
there was a building
with a mural of george floyd wearing a
crown oh yes
and a storm there was there was no there
was it was partly cloudy
and a single lightning strike hit only
the mural on the side of the building
where george floyd's face was that blew
up blew off only the outer portion of
the wall the inner wall remained intact
the roof was undamaged witnesses saw the
lightning strike it was reported by
meteorologists how the does that happen
metallic paint is all i got but only the
george floyd yes i don't know
the whole building was was it was a
mural like if they just painted his face
with some sort of metallic paint they
just blasted off all the metal or i
don't know man but the roof wasn't
damaged oh you know what i wanted and
the lightning typically strikes chimneys
i don't want to glorify people because
they got killed i want to glorify them
because of what they did in their life
and if they happen to have been killed
unjustly that's a big part of it right
but
rando people that got off is not like we
celebrate okay thank you you pointed it
out you celebrate malcolm x for what he
did in his life not for getting shot
it's what he did in his life that
matters
but but look man
they tear down statues of hans christian
heg they tear down statues of uh great
civil rights leaders even frederick
teddy roosevelt in new york city they
they took that one of my heroes man but
frederick douglass
dude it's amazing yeah he is
one of the one of the most epic
americans in the history of this country
he challenged americans right this is
this is the pre-civil war era he said he
he you are you going to live up to the
words you wrote in your own constitution
and that's like smackdown yo like do you
really believe i i i can't stand
hypocrisy if you're going to come out
and say all men are created equal we
believe in civil rights and liberty he's
gonna be like okay i challenge you to
uphold that it's brilliant and they tear
they tore his statue down up in
rochester now they want to put up
holidays for george floyd statues and
murals holiday for ahmed arby and the
georgia general assembly votes this sin
i don't know if you've seen that um that
one story tim it was actually uh the
daily signal um one of our good friends
mary margaret broke the story there was
a catholic church that had um they had
like a mural of george floyd as a saint
the dude should not have lost driving
his family around hi
like come on the guy was behind the
wheel of a car high as hell let's
celebrate all this all this movement to
like name a day after ahmad are
uh putting sane before george floyd this
just takes whatever you think of the
case cases in this case just takes the
nuance out of the discussion like five
years from now 10 years from now when
you look at a statue of george floyd or
realize that oh today's all mod arbory
day then you probably by default start
thinking that they probably must have
done something
like like good in their life right or
maybe you know they didn't and you're
like i want to be a saint how can i
because i want to be like that guy so
what it does it just whitewashes the
whole incident or just again like
removes any sort of like gray point gray
area from the discussion like these were
good people who were killed and just
that's it let's play a game
trayvon martin story initially reported
boy lies in fact i can't remember which
media outlet it was they actually edited
the 9-1-1 call from george zimmerman to
make it seem like he was racist you
remember that yeah
they asked him they jurgen says he's a
suspicious looking guy and they ask him
what race is he and he goes i think he's
black they cut that part out so it's
just george zimmerman saying a
suspicious looking guy i think he's
black like that was the sole reason they
they play these games they claim
zimmerman is a white dude he's he's his
people you know he's latino then you've
got let's see michael brown hands up
don't shoot not true
right what else do we have we have uh
with obviously ahmed arbor he was just
jogging not true george floyd not true
police footage gets released brian
taylor brennan taylor not true
none of it is true these people are evil
they are liars they are trying to
manipulate you to to take power they do
these things because it is part of their
psychotic culture revolution look we can
look at it like a zombie horde an
aimless horde of people who are doing
random things for no reason that may be
the case but if that is the case then
there is a chaotic malignancy growing in
this country that is gutting it and
destroying it yeah people
we have traditions for heroes like
frederick douglass and harriet tubman
who did amazing things that we're all
proud of and brag about yo we had people
going out like like harriet tubman was
like apparently like a badass she had a
gun and she was like super like well
trained with how to shoot and everything
like that leading people to freedom and
we're like that's what we care about we
care about freedom
frederick douglass as i already
explained these are the statues i i
think hans christian hag was my
understanding he's not even american he
would he want he fought for the north
because slavery was was a moral evil
they he died when he was 30. they tore
his statue down
it's not it has nothing to do with
racism has everything to do with erasing
and destroying our heroes our champions
our traditions
racism
not this stuff just just man it makes my
i think if they had been honest about
george floyd having all those drugs in
his system and behind the wheel of a car
with his family in the car um it would
be a different it would still be equally
as tragic and worth talking about and
but it would be a different conversation
we'd be talking about drug addiction and
how that is a big problem fentanyl
addiction yeah oh we got it we got to
give an honorable mention to jessie
smilette oh boy oh oh one of the big
laughters that's the biggest
congratulations shakti hasn't gotten
like a netflix series
can we i'm surprised cnn hasn't given
him like a role how come how come no
one's done it how come no one's made a
jessie smallett story have they done
like like
assuming the story is real
and then dramatizing the incident in
question and make like making a you know
you know they're doing the fresh prince
of bel air drama oh i heard that's so
ridiculous but the smaller thing was
like embarrassing on multiple levels to
like even for them to like sugarcoat it
i know i just think you know can we fund
this
can we do like like a satire out of it
yeah no no no totally legit
dramatization of his story
like as if it actually happened by frame
like him getting out of the subway and
the guys pulling up you might need to
change the names yeah and then i think
you'd be okay juicy
juicy
dog dogs
and i guess we i guess it would be
better if we did it as a parody because
then like he's he's in chicago at 3am
it's 20 degrees out and then like two
fat deliverance kind of guys are like
look at this pretty barn
walk up and then it's like he's like oh
no it's trump supporters
and they're like go trump and then they
start attacking him or whatever i
wouldn't believe the morphy we just said
like kanye attacked him in the morning
in chicago i'm like that's more
believable
khan is doing out of pocket all the time
yeah but but but it is i mean at least
kanye's like from he's from the east
coast
he has a reason to be there he's also
bipolar so you don't know he probably
walks the streets in the middle of the
night
yo man
at a certain point i'm just like do
these people really believe this stuff
do you see that that that canadian mp
who said that honk honk is an
abbreviation for oh like high healer i
don't even want to say god yes that's
what she said and i just i saw that i'm
like dude no sane person believes that's
true and anybody who claims to is lying
to you and also that that's like
offensive to jewish people too it's like
oh my god
yeah what if it was a jewish drug driver
yeah
so i feel like that's also offensive to
the jewish community big problem with
demonizing language
i would love to not do that do you think
we can make all the words okay again no
come on you know we're never going back
really do you think that humanity is is
that lost that our language has been
that distorted forever
dude look at what they're doing to the
spanish language but think about in even
in this conversation we can't say
certain words and i guess i'm already
brainwashed to think that words mean
certain things and they don't really
have to
what like just because i was told that
english means what it means doesn't mean
that it has to mean that sure but words
are basically
um
they're they're tools to describe things
so if we all agree racism means
something it's so that we can convey
ideas to each other the left plays
semantic games on purpose to confuse you
so you don't know how to communicate
properly it's kind of like this you're
fighting someone right
if you are uh the honorable samurai then
you approach honorably from actually no
no let's do this the american revolution
you are the british regular approaching
the battlefield with honor and the
americans are hiding in the brush and
they jump out and just ambush you
that's what the left is doing they're
doing guerrilla tactics and politics
they are trying to make sure you are
confused and tripped up and don't know
how to and it's right it seems almost
random like one day a new word will have
some other connotation or be associated
or my favorite is women
yeah you remember this
they changed women with an e to an x and
they said it was inclusive i don't even
say that out loud what'd you say
women so like so no it's whim whim w-o-m
accent so wimmix in oh we mix it
confusing as hell so it's you could say
woman or you can say
they also said you could say women's
which makes no sense because
it would be
so funny
women could you imagine being a guy at a
bar and you just walk up to a girl like
you're the finest woman next in i've
seen it
you are speaking my language but so so
check it out
imagine imagine you're you're you're
fighting someone right
here's what here's what we're doing in
this political battle we're approaching
right up front we're walking right up to
them and saying here's my argument and
then all of a sudden some guy jumps out
from behind us with a bow loss and
throws it and tangles up our feet and we
fall down and they run away laughing
they're they're playing these games
remember when um the brett weinstein
thing happened up in uh uh it was it was
seattle or evergreen college everybody
everybody yeah just outside of seattle i
think it was right and when the when the
administrators were trying to talk one
of the students goes don't wave your
hands at us it's racist so he stops and
then they all start laughing at him
they're not serious people they're
playing a a a power game and so they'll
say
oh uh latinx
latinx or whatever like no no like was
it three percent of spanish people
identify with using those terms there's
those words what does that even mean no
i mean that's like the funniest thing to
me because it's like you know obviously
i'm latino but just being
you know just i couldn't even imagine
some like white liberal going up to my
dad and being like you're a latinx and
my dad's like
uh
all right
you speak spanish yeah can you can you
speak spanish putting an x at the end of
when any any any gendered word like if
it's going to have an o or an a it's got
to be x i don't know i don't even think
you could even even do that but it would
it would be the most insane thing ever
trying to speak i mean it's just the
latinx thing is like probably the most
funniest thing to me because it's like
you have these white liberal kids who
like go to college at these universities
telling working class latinos what they
should be called and the things that
these latinos are like you know you're
like hey you're a latinx they're like um
look man i just gotta get back to work i
gotta pay bills i don't i'm not even i'm
not even in this discussion like no they
just go okay
what are you talking about what is it
what is latinx
so it's a i mean i would i guess it's a
term made by
uh by white liberals white germanic
language speaking
liberals so it's like enough taking the
non-binary out of it uh so you can't say
like latino latina
language is very famous
you know spanish language is very
engendered so like for instance like you
know if you say like
it says
that's my son this is me ha that's my
dog so everything is like that
everything is gendered so it's so weird
that i don't know why they wanted it you
know why not why not make the asian
agent say asian acts or something i
don't know why hey you know what and i
want to say this too i want to say i
think um
i think that uh spanish is sexist
against men you know why also let me ask
you let me ask you a question jorge what
is what does nina's mean it's girls like
but like little girls yeah like children
yep okay what does ninos mean
like little boys boys or
ninos yeah oh i see where you're going
what else could it mean it could also be
kids so almost to be like hey these are
the those nino so you could be like oh
these are kids so so let me let me ask
you all girls if there was a group of 10
boys and 10 girls all playing how would
you describe that ninos
ninos so that so hold on a minute you
mean to tell me that in spanish language
girls get their own special words and
can use the masculine as well
well that sounds like they get special
privileges
special descriptors that the males don't
get i'm kidding by the way but you see
that
is there some value to removing gender
from the language
mussolini
was like
the national river of italy was uh
feminine and he was like no it is a we
are strong masculine country and you
change it to a masculine word and then
they change the words
says is that necessary that kind of that
psychological power
in arabic they actually change the
language when they talk to a girl they
use different words for women i don't
know that yeah me me gotex vocus
like what are you going to do to get rid
of the gendered language like just
change the word
meet me got you could use the same word
like you don't have to no no we have
different words for man and woman yeah
who cares that latin roman romance
languages well like you said it it says
if there's boy and a girl playing
together you'd refer to them as with the
male word it's kind of like why why do
you have it there to begin with then
what are you going to say nick says
children like just
but that's that's you see like this is
the problem with the progressives
telling spanish speakers the words they
have to use because they're politically
incorrect where does it come from it
comes from latin right the the gender
stuff from the roman empire so so uh
like even french romantic man and
portuguese they have gendered language
as well yeah it all comes from latin and
that was a highly patriarchal society i
don't know maybe there's something to it
maybe maybe uh the progressives are
right and spanish people should just you
know speak the way they're told maybe
the romans built the catholic church and
uh
patriarchal language
purpose how is this not the epitome of
of white supremacy that
white wealthy liberals are telling
working-class spanish people that their
language is wrong yeah it feels pretty
uh white nighty that's why i'm glad the
polling shows it only has like two to
three percent support so
it's not working and it's a huge turn
off as a as a native speaker of spanish
you don't think there's any you have you
ever thought like that's weird or
anything
i mean to me it's completely normal i
think i mean like i said i mean i've
been raised like that it's a completely
normal thing
um
yeah i mean that's
to me that like i said the the latinx i
mean all it does is actually just hurt
the left side because it just turns off
those voters and the polling you know
shows that and i think a lot of people
forget
that a lot of these immigrant families
whether they're coming from latin
america or from china or india they're
even more conservative than your
american conservative so when you push
this type of language it's a huge turn
off and then all of a sudden those same
parents are like wait a minute it's a
little weird and then they put their
kids in public school and now they see
that their kids are being taught
you know transgenderism and kind of
sexuality education it's a it's a huge
turn-off and that one thing that means
suddenly kind of investigated a little
bit um last year was
all that all that you know sexual
education or latinx and stuff like that
that actually led to the republican win
he in virginia uh for glen younkin in
the that parent that parent uprising i
think if you watch mainstream media you
would have thought like oh man all those
parents in loudoun county are white
supremacist parents the majority of them
are like salvadorian and indian parents
who are like we don't want this it looks
like jersey up there well you guys do
you guys remember i think it was in
birmingham in the uk
it a bunch of devout muslims came out to
protest the schools right because the
schools were doing lgbtq curriculum and
that created a really weird conflict
because then all of a sudden you had
these lgbt activists coming out walking
up to niqab wearing women being like
we're doing this for you yes and they're
like we hate you yeah stop this and it's
just like
i don't know i've been to birmingham and
it's the funny thing like when you walk
the streets there are like particular
areas where you can tell that
bangladeshi people are like uh muslim
people live here and they live their own
lives they don't want to be bothered
they have their own little small mom and
pop shops and they send their kids to
the same public school where the rest of
the birmingham people go and they just
want to be left alone right and up comes
the like in uk public education is
completely completely different
than the states in so far as that
thinking of like lgbt stuff and think
thinking about you know racist like uh
race stuff is
so part of their curriculum
right from the get-go
so but these people are not used to that
so when you try to teach a bangladeshi
second generation kid that hey you got
to use this language hey you can't say
that thing hey there is no boy in gold
and he comes back
and tells his parents it's just like a
whole different environment like you
think that that stuff is awkward in the
states but in uk there is like
no conservative political ground up
school movement like turning point or
whatever in uk so like there's no
representation of like the other side of
thinking so the immigration the
immigrant population is just like in a
really like no man's land there
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you